[موسيقى]
اوحي لك ايضا الى سيادتك الى مقال كتبه
مصطفى حامد ابو الوليد المصري في خلال هذا
الشهر على موقعي الالكتروني الذي يصدر
وبغرابه من طهران هذا الموقع يصدر من طه
وهذا الرجل هو مؤرخ تنظيم القاعده له اكثر
من عشرين كتابا في التاريخ لتنظيم القاعده
كتب مقالا مهما للغايه خلال هذا الشهر عن
حرب الموانئ وحرب البحار واستدل بما يحدث
في اوكرانيا وقال ان الهجوم على
احدى المركبات او احدى السفن
الروسيه وتفجيرها هذا مهم جدا سوف يدفع
الروس للافراج عن صواريخ بحريه الى الينا
[موسيقى]
هذه الصواريخ سوف تصل الينا ومن ثم نحن
لابد علينا ان نطور ما يسمى بحروب الموانئ
وحروب البحار واول شيء واول ساحه يمكن ان
نستفيد من خلال الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
هي الساحه اليمنيه الصوماليه حيث هذه
المنطقه منطقه بحريه هامه يحدث لابد ان
يحدث تبادل وتدريب هنا ونقل الاسلحه
والتدريبات من الحوشي الى الصومال والعكس
من الصوم